good afternoon ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to this press conference
covering no less than three summits the
European Council article 50 yesterday
evening the European Council this
morning and the euro summit over lunch
now without further ado I first invite
the President of the European Council
tolerance whisk to take the floor thank
you Drebin good afternoon
let me start with breakfast yesterday
after listening to Prime Minister mais
assessments of the state of the
negotiations the eu-27 confirmed that we
want to continue the talks in a positive
spirit leaders expressed a full trust in
Michel Barnier
and asked our negotiator to continue
efforts to achieve an agreement I stand
ready to convene a European Council on
brexit if and when you negotiate reports
the decisive progress has been made and
we should be clear that for now not
enough progress has been made as there
is a lot of speculation about the length
of the transition period once the UK
leaves day you let me say this the issue
of the length of the transition period
was not discussed among that when the
eu-27 leaders yesterday but let me
recall that in half Lauren's speech in
September 2017 Prime Minister may
propose a transition period of around
two years and you accepted this proposal
anonymously
therefore if the UK decided that an
extension of the transition period would
be helpful to reach a deal I am sure
that the leaders would be ready ready to
consider this it's positively today we
also discussed migration and we
confirmed our objective to stop the flow
of illegal migration we noted in
particular they need to closely watch
the situation in the western
Mediterranean and in this context to
strengthen our cooperation with Morocco
as recommended by Prime Minister Sanchez
following our discussion in Salzburg we
also agreed conclusions on strengthening
our internal security let me mention one
issue specifically in light of the
recent hostile cyber attack carried out
against the organization for the
prohibition of chemical weapons the
European Council calls for measures to
combat illegal cyber activities in this
context we asked ministers to work on a
sanctions regime that will be specific
to cyber attacks such a regime should
help to protect our citizens companies
and institutions from all kinds of
cybersecurity threats finally on today's
euro summit the aim was to assess the
state of play of the eme reform and to
keep up the momentum for change we
agreed that we need to accelerate the
technical work we want to get an
agreement on the banking Union and the
EFM in December I hope our discussion
today will inspire the Eurogroup to act
more dynamically thank you thank you and
now the president of the European
Commission jean-claude Juncker oui yes
good afternoon
perhaps I should talk to you more about
the euro summit since then Donald has
presented the other issues on the agenda
and some detail on the euro we agreed
not for the first time that we have to
complete the banking union the capital
markets union and we should be adopting
a timetable to examine the adoption of
the deposit and guarantee and everyone
OOP and we briefly looked at him
budgetary questions which are topical at
the moment the Italian Minister
presented the Italian situation to us
with great talent and bit Flair and we
didn't ask him about that because we're
currently examining the draft budget as
am sent to us by the Italian authorities
the day before yesterday but could I
just say that we have no negative
prejudice against the Italian budget
we'll be examining it with the same
rigor and the same freedom we used to
examine other ISM but there are five or
six situations where we have to ask the
government's for additional information
but apparently I read in the press this
morning or I heard that the Commission
was about to reject the Belgian budget I
said them yesterday that the Belgian
budget was not a big problem or even a
small problem or even the problem at all
but we did have some additional
questions to ask the Belgian government
so all of those who for some
incomprehensible reason and
started looking very very carefully at
the belgian situation could I just say
that don't get excited about some things
where there's no need to
secondly we discussed the financial
prospectus so 21 27 and I was pleased to
see that no Prime Minister or Chancellor
or a dominant leader in Europe said that
we had to adopt the financial prospectus
after the elections I said as I have
done on many occasions that the fact
that there are European elections in me
does not reflect a crisis situation in
Europe it's absolutely normal to have
elections in Europe and it's possible to
take decision was right up to the last
minute and I am counting on the
colleagues in the European Council to
ensure that good budgetary decisions are
taken before the European elections it's
called as a politician I see you're
absolutely shocked by the fact that I'm
actually able to speak briefly I no open
the floor for your questions
lady Andrew please and we started Thank
You Catherine fewer you reporter
president Juncker
you said that you know journalists get a
bit overexcited and reporter sorry
apologies juries are not excited they
are bringing other people to be excited
okay but can you say whether it is there
a lack of urgency among the Heads of
Government about deepening the the
economic and monetary union do you think
that progress will only made if we are
faced
crisis do we have to wait for that to
happen before the EMU is completed we
have as a Commission presented 40
proposals concerning the deepening of
the economic amount of unit 7 6 or 7 out
of 10 have been adopted so there is a
lot of work to be done and I hope that
ministers will do so in the next coming
months
there is no sound no sense of urgency
but it's urgent
yes the you said speaking to some of my
other visual colleague that you cannot
accept everything from Italy otherwise
other member states would be very angry
too what I wanted to know whether you
found in this summit this kind of
support that you should not be too
indulgent with Italy I have to repeat
that we didn't discuss in depth the
Italian draft budget that was not the
day and not the room and not the meeting
for doing so but I know from the past
that the Commission has always been
accused for having been too generous
when it came to Italian budgets I'm not
saying that we were generous but we have
introduced in the implementation weeding
of the growth and stability pact some
elements of flexibility it having been
the only country for having used all the
flexibility instruments we have
introduced since we are since we started
as a as a commission and so I know and I
had some colleagues on the phone that
they don't want us to add flexibilities
to flexi do already existing
flexibilities and that's by the way not
our intention to to behave that way
around Italy was able to spend over the
last three years 30 billion euros more
without a
sanctioned being taken under the Empire
like the fans are saying of the
stability pact so we were very kind
gentle positive when it came to Italy
because Italy is Italy and the next
question goes to the lady in the second
row
Cathy Adler BBC president young
co-president tusk you were mentioning
their president to talk about the
possibility of extending the transition
period could their therein be found the
solution to the Irish border issue if
yes is that because there's traction now
with the idea of having a temporary
customs union for all of the United
Kingdom and if yes forgive me
does will that appear in the withdrawal
agreement and would that supersede then
the northern islands specific backstop
sorry for the multi-layers thank you it
is for so far and closes it's for me to
us to complex you know it
for me it's too easy no this
prolongation of the transitional period
probably will will happen that's a good
idea it's not the best idea the two of
us we had but I think that this is
giving us some room to prepare the
future relation in the best way possible
and I'm convinced that under the
leadership of Donald will find a deal
with Britain my working assumption is
not that we will have an OD
No Deal would be dangerous and for
Britain and for the European Union and
instead of describing the differences
divergences we have we have to
concentrate and to focus on the large
number of agreements we have and to
build up to this large number of
agreements the tools we missing elements
it will be done thank you and one more
question - Lawrence there is a
possibility that the northern islands
specific backstop could be replaced with
the idea of a uk-wide customs union
sorry - madam we are not in a
negotiation oh yeah my so it may be it's
too general and but what I can say
today's that we are in much better mood
than after vegetable and what I feel
today is that we are closer to final
solutions and and the deal but it may be
more emotional impression than rational
one but as you know emotions matters
also in politics
thanks Lawrence known of their Wall
Street Journal wood questions to
questions if I may want to each of you
for mr. tusk if indeed there is an
extension of the transition is it clear
to you the Britain would have to make
additional payments to the EU budget and
for mr. Yunker US Commerce Secretary us
surprised everyone yesterday by saying
that president Trump's patience is not
limited unlimited when it comes to trade
talks with Europe and he was suggesting
that Europe is dragging its feet over
the talks when you left the White House
meeting them mr. Trump in July did you
feel that at this stage at this point
now we would be in serious negotiations
and whose fault is it if the talks are
moving slowly if I mentioned in my
introduction the length of the
transition period so discussed among the
a 27 does yesterday and I don't want to
be a part of speculations I had a
meeting with president prompt by the end
of July and what you have agreed and
what the two of us are committed to will
be done
could I don't because we discussed
Africa this morning that was an
important element of our debates I don't
think that you mentioned it but Morocco
Morocco yeah I was Morocco North Africa
it was not only about Naraku I wanted to
say as I did during the speech on the
State of the Union that this is not
about migration we want a fair equal
partnership with the African continent
because we do think that this will be
one of the main problems we have to to
share together with the with the
Africans I will visit Tunisia later this
month and I am intending to to visit
Morocco in January February so we are
very close to the to the concerns of the
Africans but I wanted to say don't make
the mistake to think that this is only
about migration we have this external
investment program we have this African
that was fought and we have to build a
stronger economic relation with our
African friends it's not only about
migration I think you have one last
question before the awesome continued is
Eko well should you go with mr. younger
mr. young earlier on you said that might
be an agreement by the end of the year
on the European Stability Mechanism and
the banking Union you didn't talk about
the European budget euro zone budget is
that premature proposition no last year
in the State of Union speech I had
suggested that in the framework of the
general EU budget we should dedicate
some lines to the eurozone budget
whether you call it a eurozone budget or
dedicated euro zone budget lines but no
the the idea hasn't gone away this
concludes the press conference
[Music]
breaks it if and when the EU negotiated
reports in May if there is a lot of
speculation about the land let me say
this the issue of that in period of
around two years and you accepted this
proposal anonymously Dutch the situation
in the western Mediterranean and in this
context to strengthen our cooperation
with Morocco as recommended by Prime
Minister Sanchez following our dis
commitments the European Council calls
for measures to combat illegal cyber
activities euro summit the aim of to
assess the state of play of the EMU
reform and to keep up the momentum for
check produced so many lobo present a
audacity also italian avec toi avec v
avant yet she would radio kanoon new key
so openness pass the plate if put the
model is informational supramonte
machine sequester largest belgian
Exeter's you know press conference evil
system process for the Cabal she say
madam minister country East Oakland
France Leonie oak in figure dominant
Java deconsolidation Fabrizio fois kill
the FATCA legislation open on May the
reflect that under the leadership of
Donald will find a deal with Britain my
working assumption is not that we
[Music]
you